We’ve gotta get rid of these gas guzzlers
and switch to electric cars that plug into
the land of rainbows and unicorns.
Hi guys, Lissette here for DNews.
Often called “zero emissions” vehicles,
electric cars are surely better for the environment,
right?
Ehhh not so fast...Their entire life-cycle,
from manufacture to use to disposal, needs
to be considered when determining their environmental
impact.
We can’t just look at their tailpipes.
So, taking everything into consideration,
are electric vehicles actually better for
the environment than our old timey cars?
The Union of Concerned Scientists, or UCS,
recently conducted a cradle to grave study
to dig into this question, starting by comparing
the manufacturing of battery electric and
petrol cars and materials and resources used.
They used a Tesla Model S and Nissan Leaf
to represent battery-electric vehicles, also
known as BEVS, and comparable midsize and
fullsize gasoline cars.
They found that before they even hit the road
- electric vehicles actually are responsible
for about 1 ton more emissions than their
traditional counterparts.
Yes, that’s a winning point for your gasoline
powered car.
This is largely because of the BEVs lithium-ion
batteries, which require the extraction of
rare earth metals... often through drilling...
just like with oil.
Not a very eco-friendly activity.
When it comes to disposing of BEVs, they don’t
seem to be any better than regular cars either.
In fact, they may have a greater environmental
footprint because it’s tricky to dispose
of their lithium ion batteries.
But data here is lacking.
Now when on the road, BEVs don’t emit CO2,
but their batteries need to be charged from
electricity that has to come from somewhere
- and this somewhere might have a CO2 output
of its own.
A report based on 2009 national averages found
that If the electricity is coming primarily
from a country like India where coal accounts
for about 60% of electricity generated, your
BEV ends up emitting C02 at about the same
levels as a 20 mpg car.
In the US, where the fuel sources are cleaner,
this figure only rose to 40mpg - which is
basically the average for a really efficient
petrol car.
So, at this point you may be thinking, if
electric cars pollute more when they’re
built, just about the same when they’re
junked, and their battery charges can pollute
even more than an efficient gas car… then,
of course electric vehicles aren’t greener.
Figures from studies like this one are often
cited to make the case against electric vehicles.
But, here’s the thing, since 2009 BEVs have
become more efficient and while India has
added more coal powered plants, the US has
not, opting instead for renewable sources.
Looking at 2015 data, the UCS determined that
BEVs in the US are now the equivalent of cars
that go 68mpg.
And in countries like Paraguay and Iceland,
the electricity is so clean that a BEV there
would be like having a car that goes more
than 200 miles per gallon Their electricity
grids are powered by more water, wind, and
solar energy, than other countries.
When it comes to emissions, BEVs here are
many times better for the environment than
petrol cars.
What’s more, the longer you drive an electric
car, the better it stacks up against gas vehicles.
The UCS found that basically, it you drive
an EV for a month, you might as well buy a
car.
But drive that puppy for 2 years and you’re
helping the environment.
All said and done, the UCS found that electric
vehicles produce about 50 percent fewer emissions
than a regular car in the US.
Basically, the comparative environmental benefits
increase the more you drive and the cleaner
the electricity source.
CTA video
Now, we are of course, only talking about
global warming emissions, we’re not saying
that one type of car is better than another.
You might have personal preference for other
reasons.
Maybe you’re into salt powered cars.
To learn more about those guys, check out
this episode here.
River Monsters push
Now, if you’re a fan of the biggest and
baddest water creatures, you can watch the
full, season premier of River Monsters online
now.
Just click the link in the video description
below and catch new episodes of Season 8 every
Thursday on Animal Planet.
What’s your favorite car?
Do you prefer petrol, electric, hybrid, diesel,
something else?
Share your thoughts in the comments and remember
to subscribe so you never miss an episode
of DNews.
Thanks for watching.